啊，上课了啊。
今天上点啥呢？
老有同学问呢，那问说老师能不能讲讲格式，再讲讲格式。
我其实讲了呀剧本的格式，而且我说过，你说你你要剧本的格式，我把剧我把剧本发给你吗？找个找个好剧本给你看看不就完了吗？
对吧而且剧本格式我也说了。
几号字，哪些顶头，哪些居中用啥符号。我说这些其实没有那么重要。你要是能写好了，这些格式错了，人人家也不会怪你人调也调不完。
后来还是有同学问我我有点想明白了，我感觉你们好像不是真的是在问剧本的格式，你们没表达清楚。
其实你是不知道一场一场的戏应该怎么去设置。
就说这一场戏里面。
啊，这个这个环境应该怎么样的去刻画动作，怎么去描述对白。
怎么去撰写？
其实是这个没搞懂。
确实啊是我本位主义了。我总以为说咱们把故事讲好了之后。
这些这个这个一场一场的戏自动就出来了。
呃，我本位主义了啊，因为我干这个干了十来年了，我总以为这个是小事儿。所以咱今天。
把这个再再再讲一遍，好吧，再详细说说吧，这节课就叫。
场景。
一对白把这俩事儿研究研究咱们好吧。
场景也就白。
就说这个这个剧本啊。
咱们前面写过梗概。
又写大纲，然后后来呢开始写这个。
事件序列嘛，我说开始的时候叫叫第一个单位啊。
这个剧本的第一个单位叫木对吧？一目一幕的嘛，分成三目还是四目一大块一大块的。后来呢我又说呃整整这个序列或者叫事件群，我说分10个左右。
对吧有的教材要分10个，有的教材要分1多个，怎么分都行。
呃，事件群序列是事件群。
然后你再往下落实，再往下小，其实就到场了。
他最终呈现。
最终呈现给给给给给各制作单位拿着你这个剧本执行的时候，他们看到是一场一场戏。
场又叫场景，有些书上翻成场景。
他呢。
就是剧本的。
最基本的。
单位。
也有说叫最小的单位的。
就是最基本的构成是由一场一场戏的构成。
所以很多同学可能是到这儿。
迷糊了。
不知道这一场一场的戏应该怎么写。那我们接来今天就来。
呃，说说这个事儿。
说说这个事儿。
说说这个场或者是说叫唐鼎。
那首先说场景是个啥？我我那节课我有一节课简单说过。
我说他就是。
一般来说就是一个。
一个地点或者是一个环境。
一个摄像机所能覆盖的。
范围里面出了事儿，你就按这说是异常。
他的完整定义是这么说的，是。
呃，统一空间和连续时间内。
发生的故事，或者说是叫。
在这个统统一。
空间和连续时间内的故事场面吧。所以它其实是一个时空的概念嘛。
时间空间的概念。
啥叫统一统一空间，连续时间内的。
我那节课给大家举的例子说一个人在在在在这个办公室里打电话。
叨逼叨叨逼叨在那一直说，这就是一场戏。你说他其中因为哎有几句话说的不便之处，不想让这一个办公室的同事听到他走到阳台上去打了。
你说。
换换没换场，我说都可以，因为它也是统一呃统一统一空间的办公室的阳台嘛。
他也没有出圈，然后呢，又是连续时间的一个一个还是在打电话，等于是同一时空的。哪怕他走到走廊里面又打了一会儿。
也可以。
我就说高时其实。
就是这么简单给大家说了一下。
这个分场。
呃呃，其实还有很多例子啊，你像你说。
那个那个那个什么功夫里面哎，功夫里面，周星星和那个火云学生打架，然后呱嚓一个飞腿，把火云鞋生踹出去了，咚咚咚咚咚咚咚，连续穿了好多个房间，穿到裁缝铺，穿到包子铺，对吧？穿到理发店，那你说你没进一个场景就换一场戏吗？
第35场火云邪神从北墙穿到南墙就理发店。第三0下一场是那个包子铺，火云邪神从南墙穿到北墙，没有必要一直换场，那就是咚咣咚被踹出去了，完事了，对吧？还有追逐戏，你说来追逐戏。
那种街头追逐戏啊。
比如说在一个那个贫民窟里面逃命，被人追杀，他也要穿很多场景呀，一会儿进到这个呃房间，一会儿又躲到这个超市里面，然后又从这个呃一那个那个一家饭店的后门又钻出去。
也没必要去去。
去挨个分。
所以说这个分场啊。
你怎么去分，不是完全按照地点。
去分的你要么是统一场景，统一呃空间，要么是连续时间这么一个一个事件。
或者是叫一个故事场场场面。
这就叫一个场景。
那具体落实在咱们的剧本里面。比如说咱们在写这个一场一场戏的时候。
咱们手里实际上是有一个。
大纲了。
对不对？我教过大家呀，你要先写梗概，再写你的大纲万字纲一般是一万字左右，然后把这个大纲再去变成。
一场一场的。
具体的。
场景了。
在这个时候，你怎么去变，怎么去写。
我们这节课来说一下场景的。
写的时候的几个要点和要遵循的原则。好吧。首先我们说一个场景。
或者说叫一场戏，一般来说是有自己的完整的。
开端、高潮和结局的。
也就是说，场景一般来说也可以视作一个小故事。
也可以视作一个小故事。
他是有。
它是有体成转合的。
就是他是有要素的。
明白这个意思吧？
场景不是说你换一个地方打一枪，换一个地方，这就叫完成了一场戏了。
他是有自己的要素。
可以视为一个小单元小故事的，这才能成为场景是是剧本的一个基本单元嘛。
然后我们说场景的作用。
你写分成这么一场一场的戏，这一场场上的戏要扛事的。
他要有作用，你才你才写他的。
我们的场景的作用。
有哪些？
首先。
传达信息。
这是最最经最常见的一个作用。比如说你这场戏。
去到男主角家里。
那么你首先就要传达这个男主角的身份。
他的生活状态。
对吧然后他的他贫穷还是富裕，然后有没有女伴儿？
生活的这个这个。
呃，是个邋特的人，还是个整整洁的人？
传达很多信息。
就是。
因为你在你的大纲里面啊，其实你有一肚子话想告诉观众，明白我意思吗？
所以说传达信息就是这个意思，你写了好多。
那个那个甚至连这个呃这个呃，比如说这个你你你在你的大纲里面，你写这个男主角离过两次婚。
对吧然后有一个6岁的女儿。
但是你在整个戏里面，这个这个他他前妻和他女儿又没出现。
你就。
他不在故事中这俩人。
但是这个信息你又想表达。
那你就可以通过这一场戏里面。
他的环境来表达吗？家里有。
女儿的东西女儿的照片还是什么的？
总之。
他要表达你。
在大纲里面。
想要谋划的那些信息，你使了使了浑身的劲儿，写了好多信息，现在在剧本里面变成一场一场的戏了。
你那些信息无处安放，无处表达。
你你就是这这一场一场的戏，就是你最后的手段了。你你现在没有那些花里胡哨的描述了。
没有机会了，现在就是一场一场具体的戏，这个戏里面就三样东西。
这戏里面就三样东西。
环境。
动作。
对白。
也就是说，你前面。
吭哧吭哧的写了那么多东西，想表达那么多东西。
你现在只有三样东西了，你现在只有三个最后的手段了，环境动作和对白。
他们都在场景里面。
你需要用这些把你的所有想要表达的信息表达掉，有用的信息啊，没用的信息别瞎表达了。所以在大纲的时候，我已经提醒过大家，不要瞎给我写那个这个老张呃表面冷漠，内心狂热，对吧？没有用就别写了。
老张抠门。
对剧情有用。
那可以写。
通过一场戏还是一个细节，把这个信息传达掉，他抠门。
对吧有时候一个动作，一个眼神也可以传达掉，或者是用对白传达掉，他抠门。
重置。
一场一场的戏第一个作用。
就是传达信息。
然后第二个作用。
就推进。
推进。
就说戏啊啊这个场景啊。
他是在序列下面的，我们说10个序列。
这10个序列是10个大的事件群，在这个序列里面。
他是要办点大事儿的。
所以一场他在分割成一场一场的时候，往往需要推进你的张力。
就是这场戏。
我前面那个序列。
是一个比如说是一个非常危险的一次。
大冒险是一次危险的行动。
那么我前面的每一场都要。
增加这个危险，推进这个张力。我经常说嘛，比如说。
我们现在男主角。
前面有个很大的危险。
比如说他要去去去去。
去闯这个龙潭虎穴。
对方很凶残。
那这个是个大危机吗？
你要增加你要逐步增加这个张力，增强这个烈度。那前面的几场戏，你就要在这几场戏里面就要下手做这件事了。比如说去的路上枪他妈丢了。
对吧那你这样一个动作不就更增加了你后面那个危险。
会更危险吗？
对吧然后又走到一半，进到这个大楼里面，发现哎呦，我操手机又没信号了。
你没办法报警了，没办法。
找援兵了。
所以就是。
推进作用。
既然他是序列下面的单位，你要帮助序列完成序列的任务呀。
明白这个意思吗？能理解吗？就是序列有他的任务。
有他的作用。这场戏比如说就是要男主陷入危险这个整个系列序列里面这个事件全是让男主陷入危险。那么你分成你下面的小弟一场一场的戏，你就要逐步推进这个。
这个大任务呀。
所以叫要推进。
或者叫增强一步一步增强。
个张力一步一步烘托起来。
所以说这是。
这个这个场景的另外一个作用。
这都是祸者啊或者啊。
也可以，当然也可以既传达信息又推进好吧，然后还有一场一场戏，那除了推进，那肯定还有。
转折的时候嘛。
或者叫变化的时候嘛。
这个是最常最常见的一个状态。其实。
就是说你这场戏里面。
一般来说会有点变化了。
否则的话，这场戏。
也写也写的也。
似乎是可以删掉的。我们讲。
写完某你的场景写完之后啊，你先信着写，你先由着你的感觉写，拿着你的大纲好这一万字的大纲，然后感觉嗯这儿可以来这儿到这儿又是一场。哎，马上又起一场。哎呀，开着车过去又是一场，路上又呃那个那个碰到熟人又一场，然后又打了个电话又一场。
你就那么一场一场，你先信着写，到最后你肯定是需要大量的删减。
和合并的。
明白这个意思吗？
因为你每一场戏里眠都需要来点儿。
转折或者变化。
你才能保证这场戏不白写，不白瞎。所以说。
场景或者说一场戏的作用，一般来说有。
传达你的信息。
因为你有很多要表达的，只要大纲是你自己写的，你会发现到时候你有很多无处安放的表达，无处安放的信息。所以要传达信息。第二呢，要推进推进啥意思呢？就是完成你序你是大序列下面的吗？完成你的序列任务。
你需要多次推进一个危险，序年是一个危险。那么你需要多次推进这个危险，你不可能一下子到达啊最危险呀，一场一场的推。
然后呢。
转折和变化。
一场戏里面往往是包含包含一定的转折和变化的，哪怕是推进，我正在完成推进的任务。
来，我这个这个男主角要闯这个龙潭虎穴。
然后我们不是说他有我有一场戏是把枪丢了吗？
把枪丢了，首先表达这个信息。否首先这场戏其实是有信息的。我们这个男主并不是一个什么很专业的那种杀手或者是什么呀，这枪有可能都是借的，你知道吗？现借的，然后那个套也不会用，所以丢了，等于是传达了这个信息，然后。
推进我们说让危险更危险嘛，这场戏是危险，这个系序列的作用是男主。
勇闯这个龙潭虎穴是一个很危险的事情，甚至是一个送词的事情。那么我们是不是推荐了这件事情呢？
然后同时这场戏里面是有变化和转折的嘛，小变化小转折他们枪丢了呀。
汤丢了呀。
明白这个意思吗？
所以说。
这个这个每场戏都是要有作用的。
都是要有作用的。你写完之后，第二遍检查的时候发现没有作用。这场戏是要考虑合并或者删掉的。
啊，这是场景的作用。
然后我们说让你的场景精彩起来。
你的场景还要遵循这样一个原则，就是一进一出。
需要是动作。
通常来说，你的场景一进一出是动作。
就是你在动作中进息。
在动作中出戏。
这个不太好理解是吧？
这么说吧。
假设啊。
假设你写这么一场戏。
呃黑一个黑老大。
黑帮大佬。
在这里在房间里。
这个比如说正在吃吃面。
对吧我们说黑帮大佬一般会设计他做一点很接地气的事，显得这个大佬是有人人人情味的，是有不是人情味儿，是有人人气的，他也是有烦人该做的事情。所以一般吃的东西还不是不是太好，对吧？特别爱吃这个这个比如说炸酱面。
咸蛋黄长拌面，在那拿一堆咸蛋黄在那拌面吃。
然后这个黑帮大佬，然后一个小弟进来说大哥。
调查清楚了。
您的拜马子兄弟。
确实。
背叛你了。
确实背叛你了。
呃。
咱们。
舞厅的钱。
他黑了不少，他黑了200万。
啊，老大继续在那吃，对吧？然后就来汇报这个他还这个这个。
勾结对方呃，勾结我们的。
对手，然后呢他还。
四处说您坏话，他还怎么着吧，反正。
这么一场戏。
我们说正常我们来写的话啊。
我们就会写啊这个老大在干什么。然后呢，这个小弟走进来，然后呢汇报汇报完了之后呢，小弟走了，然后老大呢呃那个陷入沉思或者是发飙了还是怎么着？你这样的话，你的进进和出都是状态戏，这种戏的话就不太好，就不太符合这个场场景。
的要求，你看你老大那小弟进来的时候。
他在那吃面，吃面不是动作戏啊，这个不是个无效动作，因为它不带来不带来效果。
他其实是状态系。
来。
你完全可以改成这场戏的开端，是小弟进来。
就老大在吃面。
小弟一下冲进来。
影响了老大吃面，这就是动作了。这个动作是有效的嘛。比如说把老大吓了一跳，他妈咸蛋黄上掉地上了。
然后一抬头，小弟开始汇报。
汇报完了之后。
不要小弟走了。
这个这个这个老大还在这儿沉思一会儿，又变成状态了。汇报就是也是动洞。
也是在动作中结束这场戏，跟老大汇报说。
黑了呃那个那个夜总会200万。
继续吃面对吧？心疼妈的，我这闲蛋花掉了，不当回事，还在心疼自己的面，对吧？那个老大他还四处说您坏话啊，还是不理老大他。
呃，他还那个勾结呃我们的对手啊啊大还没有点区别。
老大他还睡了你的马字，那老大10多盖死他，对吧？然后起身一骑结束这场戏。
在动作中进，在动作中出，为什么要这么做呢？这样的话会让你的戏啊让你的整个电影更流畅。
就说你的电影会动起来。
我们说这个电影要流动起来啊。
你如果每一场戏都写都是状态进，状态出。
那么你的戏很容易。
很容易出现这个这个死气沉沉的一个状态。
所以你记住这个这个要点就是。
每一场戏在动作中进，动作中出怎么做呢？就是你还是信着写，你还是跟着你的感觉写。写完之后，你把每一场戏给我掐头去尾。
就像我说的，你本来写那个老大在那吃面。
怎么吃的吃着吃着小弟推门进，掐头去尾，把这个头砍掉。
就嘣小弟推门进。
一边跟老大说，老大在吃面也来得及，你想要他吃面这个信息OK没问题。但是。
动作中进明白这个意思吗？
你现在不理解不要紧，你给我记住这个口诀，修改的时候记住这个口诀，它可以让你的戏流畅起来流动起来。你记得去掐头去尾，记得让他动作中进，动作中出。
动作中处。
我们说这是一个原则，还有一个原则就是。
在场景中。
一定要有对抗。
我们说对抗是啥意思？
我们前面讲要素的时候讲过。
对抗分三种。
就是角色。
和环境的对抗和对手的对抗，以及和自己的对抗。
一定要包含一种对抗。
啊，包含至少一种对抗。
你这场戏才有看点。
他有看点。
你那你说刚才这场戏这小弟走进来说这个大佬这个这个这个。
二当家，你那拜把子兄弟。
是个二五仔。
对吧他出卖你了。
有没有对抗？当然有对抗啊，他前面说他你的拜把兄弟诶黑了你前了，老大没生气啊，没抬头，他当初说你坏话，没抬头。
那个那个呃他。
呃，他还勾结我们的对手，老大还是没抬头。
为啥他能不生气吗？他生气，他这是角色跟自己的对抗。
你在这里故意写这场戏，是因为这个你肯定这个戏里面你这个黑老大这个角色他跟自己是有对抗的，他割舍不下这份兄弟情。
他还是认这个拜把子兄弟的。
呃，这些事儿跟他说的时候，他认为这是小事儿，所以他没抬头，直到他说他睡了你爪子，咔那么炸酱面往地上一摔，不吃了，对吧？要干呢。
所以说你每这个每一场戏呀。
检查的时候看一看它有没有包含一种对抗。
然后一般来说还要包含一个转折。
或者叫反转呢。
书上说叫反转，其实就是我说的这里。
对吧你是会有变化的。
包含一次反转。
就是让你这个戏有看头，包含一次也不叫变化，包含一个反转意思就是包含一个让人出人意料的地方。
包含一个点，出人意料，你这场戏才算完成任务了。
否则的话，你这是还是我说的，你这场戏你就考虑要不要删掉。
因为你删掉以后。
比如说你这场戏本来有信息，但是呢就缺乏后面的推进和转折。
然后你把这场戏删了，那你再把这些信息。
放到别的场次里面去表达不就好了吗？因为信息。
他是暗藏在。
每一场戏里面呢你完全可以给他挪个地儿。你如果没有后面的这个东西的话，你只表达的信息，你其实可以考虑。
让西删掉的，然后把这个信息这个这个任务包。
装载到别的场次里面，是这么一个思维。
就是每一场戏啊你要有一场一场，他是你的兵，他是你的零件儿这种思维。他帮你办事儿。你当你发现他办的事儿不够多，或者是不够漂亮，没有反转，或者没有对抗这场戏不漂亮。他仅仅是为了交代信息。
你还丁光写了一场戏，仅仅是为了交代。
呃，这个黑老大特别爱吃炸酱面，为什么爱吃炸酱面呢？是因为小时候他家里穷，所以对炸酱面有执念，这是一个黑老大可爱的地方对，是有这个作用啊，这个作用是有的，这个信息是有用的。
但是你一整场戏只表达这个信息。
是不行的，你这场戏就要考虑删掉了。然后呢。
吃炸酱面，小时候家里穷，所以爱吃炸酱面，就咸蛋呃咸蛋黄这个信息包。
把它装载造。
别的一场戏里面，对吧？他前面一场戏在比如说在那个那个审讯殴打一个一个小弟，那你就在让他在那场戏里面吃面吗？
那你这场戏不就删掉了吗？
到最后你的剧本一定是做减法，不是做加法，明白这个意思吗？不要心疼。
做减法，你的戏才会越来越流畅。
所以说这就是。
我们说的这个这个。
呃，剧本的最小单位场或者叫场景。
他就是这么写的。
他就是这么写的，他一般来说包含环境描述、动作描述和对白。然后呢它的作用就是这些它的注意事项就是这些。
明白吗？
我给大家。
举个例子啊。
我们看一场戏。
你可能就能更明白。
我说的这些。
这个一个场景的这些方法和注意事项。我们看一下这个戏叫呃better call all风骚律师。我前面提过这个戏啊，是一个美剧，但是它是按照电影格式写的。
他第一季第一集里面。
的一场戏，开场没多久的一场戏，大家先看一下，好吧。
9456005448960643 and the expiration is 1104 Okay, and the key word here is classy all right, super classy, use only flowers that look expensive but you know aren't.
And the notes should sayD Betsy and Craig, best wishes from your stickler for justice, James McGll, okay and McGll spelled MC.
Run it again.
Well no, no, no, it's paid up, run it again.
Okay say something what you do what do my brother I out nowhere freak ran over ran over my brother the whole thing on video accident accident me it's.
police?
Fll, what can I do to make it right?
这呢。
翻一算这道是。
80%。
Man listen is Starlight Express I'm going to give you an 9.6 for technique 0.0 for choice of victim I'm a lawyer does a steaming pile of craft scream payday to youhuh the only way that entire car is worth $500 bucks is if there's a $300 hooker sitting in it now let's talk about what you owe me for the windshield.
真有怪。
Take a check.
好啊。
刚才这场戏大家看了吧，这个男主就是我们说的骚是这个戏的男主角。
他开着车边开车边打电话，然后遭遇了一次车祸。
两个小伙子玩滑板。
跟他的车发生事故了，然后呢，问他要钱。
他识破了这两个。
这俩小子是碰瓷的，然后俩小子逃跑。
就是这么一场戏，我们来逐个比对一下。
逐个比对一下。
我们说首先他是个小故事吧。
他是不是有要素？
它有提升转合呀，很完整啊。也就是说这场戏你其实你如果你没有看过整部剧，你也能看明白这场戏。
明白这个意思吗？大概能看明白这场戏吧。
这个事儿是明白的，它是完整的。所以说它是有要素的。我们说它的作用你看啊。
信息推进和转折都有没有？
我们说这这一场戏啊。
我因为看过整部戏，我告诉你这这场戏传达了多少信息。
他开始的时候开车的时候，他是在打电话，对不对？他打电话在干嘛？
他打电话在订花。
订花送给。
一个人。
这个人呢是他的客户。
表达了什么信息呢？
上一场戏当然上一场戏他是在是他在跟这个客户谈生意，他是个律师，想要代理这个客户的官司。但是这个客户似乎对他不太满意，这是上一场戏。那么这一场戏这个信息就表明了什么？他迫切的想争取这个客户。
这个信息先表达了吧。第一，这个信息表达了吧。
很想争取这个客户。
然后这他开的这个车大家看到了，是个很破的车，对不对？
那他很穷很穷，很想争争取这个客户一切都合逻辑。然后给这个。
呃，客户订花送花对吧？然后订花送花的过程中，他为什么会出这个车祸，他自己也不小心吧。
他边开车边在打电边在打电话，又表达了一个什么信息呢？说明这个律师啊也不是很讲究。
不是很讲究法律，开车打电话违法的呀。
那他边开车边打电话，而且他开不光边开车边一个手拿着电话，另外一个手还拿着信用卡。
有没有看到这个他拿着信用卡在那在那儿读他信用卡号，这又表达了一个什么？
表达了一个什么呢？就美国人啊，美国人消费都是用信用卡的。
就是你买定一个什么东西，你把你的信用卡号报给人家。
就可以了。
正常人。
都是这么消费的。
按道理来说啊，你的信用卡。
你应该背的滚瓜烂熟。
你就应该背的已经滚瓜烂熟了，因为你一直用这个信用卡。
你老信老换信用卡，那说明什么问题呢？
说明你不光穷，你这信用卡还有问题。
你经常拆东墙补西墙，甚至办假的卡。
就说明这个律师啊绝对不是一个正八经的律师。
不是很讲究，而且开车还危险驾驶，一边打电话，一边还在那读信用卡。
啊吧这些信息其实都表达了。
然后这两个小子。
我们当然看到后面知道他是碰瓷了啊，这小子碰瓷以后。
来讹诈这个这个这个这个我们这个男主角，这个律师，我们这个男主角没有上套，识破了他们的伎俩，而且还装可怜把他们耍了一把，然后开始辱骂他们，告诉他们你们。
玩错人了，我他妈是祖师祖师爷，还跟我这闹。
又传达了一个什么信息？
说明我们这个这个律师啊很野路子，江湖经验很足，不是那么好欺负的对吧？所以信息传达的。
是很多很到位的。
然后我们说。
推进有吗？推进有。
你看我后面的剧情，你就知道，就这两个碰瓷的小子。
我们说他开始的时候在打电话争取一个客户，不太想让他代理官司的客户。然后呢，遭遇了碰瓷的两个小痞子。
他下一场戏就是去找。
那他在后面的戏里面啊，他在完全去他在确定这个客户已经完全没有希望。
呃，代理下来的时候，他铤而走险，他做了一个什么样的过激行为呢？他雇佣这两个碰瓷的小子跟他们说，哎，你们俩不是爱碰瓷吗？不是想挣500块钱吗？我给你们1000。
那那俩小子说，那干嘛，所以你们不我去碰个词，他雇佣那两个小子去碰瓷，他想要争取的这个客户。
等于是他想让这两个小子碰瓷这个客户，然后他突然出现说，哎，怎么出车祸了。哎哎，你别别搭理他俩，然后他扮演一场英雄救美，展现一下他超超超凡的律师技能，让他的客户觉得哇，今天多亏了你。那我那个官司，你也帮我打了吧，这是他的美好如意算盘。
所以说这这场戏推进剧情的作用是非常明确的。这俩碰瓷的小子，他后面要用的，包括他争取不到这个客户，也在这场戏里面。
都埋好伏笔了。
明白吗？然后转折呃这个更不用说了更不用说了。
开始我们都以为他要上当了，或者是我们也没有意识到这俩人是碰瓷，但是他来来了一个反转，对吧？你们太太嫩了吧。
对吧虽然我危险驾驶了，但是我也没看转向灯，我我我没开转向灯，没看红绿灯，我就转弯了。但是你们两个。
呃，别想这个在关公面前耍大刀，也是有转折的。
那我们说来这场戏的进出。
都是动作，毫无疑问吧。
毫无疑问吧。
进就是开着车进的，开着车打电话进的。
每个动作都是有用的。
然后出的时候非常干脆，这两个小子一他一识破，这俩小子一跑，这场戏马上结束。
他没有在写，他懊恼的看了看，哎呀，大风玻璃碎的很心疼。哎呀，会上到车，哎，要开车走，没有这些。
呃，这个这个额外的东西，俩小子一跑。
这俩小子跑是有效动作，表示你没抓住他们吗？就结束后面那些无效动作。
观众能想象到他后面会很生气的上车开着走，骂骂咧咧的走了。
没有。
无效动作，那是那叫状态，无效动作视为状态。
所以是状态键呃，动作键中动作出。
没有毛病吧？
然后我们说对抗有吗？
当然有了，我们这个这个这场戏里面这个这个这个so这个律师是我们的男主角啊。
他首先对抗环境呀。
贫穷啊。
对吧他对抗环境呀。
贫穷，然后他的律师路不是很顺，他在律师这个行业很挣扎，这就是他的环境呀，他对抗非常。
非常明确的表达给观众了，这是一个很挣扎的律师呀。然后对手更明确了，打那个电话那个客户其实就是他的对手。
不给他官司，不给他代理权呀，然后撞这俩小B也是他的对手呀，给他找事儿，把他挡风玻璃还给干干碎了。
一路都是对手，一路都是对抗，对吧？反转。
这这这场戏就是让你看反转的呀，对吧？所以我们说你看这这是就是一场很简单的戏。
很简单的戏很干净，人物也不多，场景也很很呃很很统一，马路上对吧？
就是我说的这是一场。
合格的精彩的戏。
是是要保留的，因为他办了这些所有的事儿。
所以大家就是在写。
这个自己的把自己的大纲变成一场一场的戏的时候。
就要注意这些事项。
我之所以之之前一直没有去专门去讲场景或者是剧本格式这一块，是因为我十分担心一件事情，就是有的同学啊。
觉得自己呃天赋异禀，上来就搞这个。
上来就写这个，我告诉你没有一个编剧敢这么做。
你是不可能成功的。
因为你每一场戏你都会失去方向，失去你不知道你写这场戏干什么。
明白这个意思吗？
你还是要先把故事写完。
然后再把它安排进每一场。
安排进每一场。
有的这是这是一条重要的信息。你你你说啊，那我需要通过环境把这场信息交代掉，或者是需要一个小动作把这场环境交代掉，或者是我在词里面把这个信息交代掉。然后呃这这里又有一个什么事儿呃，这个事儿可以分成多少场戏去表达？
你一定要先有你的大纲。
再去写这个玩意儿，一定不要上来就给我搞这个上来第一场，哎呀，这个马路什么这你你别瞎搞，不要来这一套做不好的那不可能的，好吗？所以说明白了吗？
明白了吧？
这就是。
我们说的。
它是剧本的最小的单位。
这么一场一场的戏。
一场一场戏就是这么写出来的。
好吧。